I tried to make my look at here because
Grammy hi my name is fear something if
you don't know now you know your life is
different now you can read eternal
videos let's get right into it
caveat I have not watched the Grammys at
all tonight they're currently still
happening I've been seeing lots of
tweets from Tyler Oakley about how shook
he is oh there's another ones I'm sure
much has happened I have no idea I'm
just here to look at the fabrics on
their bodies let's do it grill it
this is like how I think I love to the
rest of the world on a daily basis but
deep down I know it's incorrect yes
extraordinarily similar aesthetic
t-shirt with chain necklace and time
spent messing here I like that you look
like Skrillex so that's cool that's one
thing only about the Grammys is that it
feels like there's no pressure to be
completely formal you can have more fun
another thing that this is like super
fun but you don't have to be buttoned
down literally not a single button there
Tori Kelly you're the green dress blond
haired version of that flamenco dancer
emoji very millennial I spent a lot of
previous patch review videos that or
choice in silico tea smelling of sparks
multiple farts a symphony of hearts on
the red carpet and this looks like your
star like the talent of one small
possible Park yeah and yeah I had no
idea this is what an you looks like I
use the Enya song in so many of my
videos and I had no idea what she ever
looked like ever you look like you could
be a second grade teachers that got a
makeover on like the Today Show you are
so nice looking until this is nice
Joey told straight over a carpet on me
I'm a big fan she's just gonna pose
elegant aesthetic to her but I know you
drink whiskey and get crazy which is why
I just want to be friends with you but I
know
hello King you look like Coachella King
I'll exit it oh yeah I really like this
because the dress is super elegant and
feminine and the flower crown but our
tattoos are still out and proud and I
would love to see her just change
broking about cigarettes and shooting
whiskey is that for some reason it just
it all makes sense
this is like putting pepperoni and a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich frying
secret you look like a couch a cute
couch you know but you look like Bruno
Mars just you and that's cute cute girl
crush another real Buffett unless you've
got like a dirty old band-aid floating
around master okay cute this Lo you look
like a professor priest Lady gaga yeah
yes yes yes yes yeah yeah yeah yes
that's the magic 8-ball outlook yeah
give up a new era of weird oh this makes
me so happy naga is a taurus li r AZ on
the red carpet in terms of fashion and
it's got a little tame and then yeah
give us biker badass here every
available part of my chest i'm allowed
to show us NM BDM mmm chic hi described
stuffing I love this we got leather
diaper arms that look like sexy car wash
washers you're bringing back the chain
wallet the boots looks extremely
complicated and your Shona liberal boobs
that we don't get to see very often so
thank you God
Rihanna okay cumbersome at its best
I don't hate this glamorous 40 spice on
top layered up cycled truck tires on the
bottom alright I'm all for that John
Legend you look adorable you look fancy
be having fun look when you're tied
you're still in like a fountain pen
explode on your tie or in some sort of
pattern either way you've got that
permanent I'm having a decent time for
my
your face classic you cute taraji PE
Tencent stop stop stop stop stop
I want to own this dress it looks like
you found a really beautiful purple
second dress and you made a quick trip
to join us fabrics and DIY this [ __ ] out
of it
packages are very trendy this season I'm
into it chance the rapper
I would love appropriate with you no
pressure just throwing it out there you
always look so good and interesting and
cool and hip and fun and adorable and
you always seem like you're having the
best time ever a good attitude never
goes out of style
I'm would like to jet and tomorrow's
knows oh girl yes you look like a
decoration that I got from Party City
for like a graduation party that was
kind of bent out of shape but then you
made it into a dress it looks good I
like this outfit the symmetry that [ __ ]
is really pretty to lean beyond yes
what oh you look amazing oh my god I am
talking about your insurance if you're
like a dog that I've never met before it
is read into my house and like you look
beautiful where'd you get that kiss
plate cratenbarrel
Jennifer Lopez oh okay
awesome just gonna point out that this
area of the female body very trendy this
grammy-award red carpet to showcase like
it it's very if bag up top and Christian
got it on the bottom unexpected combo
cute katharine McPhee everything's very
sweet like I mean I've been put into
place so it's a little bit like you
might take them off it but that's a
taste
Laverne Cox don't do this don't do that
don't do this don't do this don't do
this this is very good Katy Perry oh can
I say I really like blonde Katy Perry I
can I have to say I'm really not trying
to copy her hairstyle
I like everything that's happening here
so many textures so many fabric it looks
a little bit like a muppet
the Grammys dresses Katy Perry it's not
in queue to carry mass and just like
trying to put dress on as far as I could
and they couldn't get the element on
their mothers about is there like never
rule just hold on to the dance area Demi
Lovato oh you look like the sexiest
doily I've ever seen like I said this
area died boob fishball give us inner
boob 2017
you look amazing you look like a sexy
dream catcher from Urban Outfitters I'm
into it they tell got this this area
memo I think this is pretty you were in
a red dress you look pretty
I didn't want to say about it Heidi Klum
is there she is
yes I missed you girl and I guess a
pretty conservative for you this is
subtle chain mail dress all right
you do look a little bit like you're
going out for the night on the Jersey
Shore but a real elegant though very
very elegant though you're NEX how many
free test-tube shot Charli XCX oh this
is so elegant also I've no idea where
the carpet stops and your dress starts
and that's cool Carrie Underwood also
gotten that in your boob memo and you're
doing another red carpet as a dress
guest but with glitter on it you I don't
say though I'm a little concerned about
the foot that goes straight up into the
vagina but maybe it's far more
breathable so you do you girl palsy okay
yeah why not we got our Arab ooh thank
God a depleted cargo Hammer pants it's
like you just every trend that the guys
could wear to not get laid and put them
all into one pant and you were like I
could find anyone that I want to succeed
mafia inspired track jacket on top and
like Virgin IT guy glamour on the bottom
why not Nick Jonas got a break han and
owns a bedazzler apparently pentatonic
you guys look incredible you look this
kid edgy fun young talented kind
rounded koi pond is full of humility
work ethic and Simon body is failing
because I'm just Beyonce
it's Egyptian space Coachella and I
wasn't ready this is how you do a flower
crown this is like Virgin Mary imagery
Cleopatra meets modern day Coachella and
chain mail week tribal flower child
she's just she just decided to do every
genre of everything all at once and I
believe in carbecue okay there is my
commentary on the Grammys red-carpet
fashions let me know what you guys
thought and what your favorite look was
in the comment section down below and if
you liked this video give it a thumbs up
and click this button to subscribe to
this YouTube channel
um my brain has mica I'm going to I
can't I'm I have to leave now because I
have to go watch bounces performance
okay you understand I don't know
Cee Lo Green yeah this is good I hope
this is commentary on how the emmy
trophy has an unrealistic body image and
this is presenting an alternative
healthy realistic body image trophy
figurine thank you